I apologize to the people of Denmark and of Scandinavia. Bryce is trying to take away your ranking. We've got two hours and ten minutes, it says, until we get to Copenhagen. Probably going to run out of stickers. We'll save that discussion for when it happens. Use modern C++. Polestar, it's a big swing to miss. And also, it's not like a, you know, a microcontroller.
我向丹麦和斯堪的纳维亚人民道歉。Bryce 试图夺走你们的排名。上面显示我们距离哥本哈根还有两小时十分钟。贴纸可能要用完了。我们等到了那时候再讨论。使用现代 C++。Polestar，这步棋走得有点大，而且它不像，你知道的，微控制器。
They're running Linux there, but it's a limited memory environment. Basically, everyone at Roku listens to ADSP. Cheetah, like, you know, going after this Impala. And buy Tesla next time, folks. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 254 recorded on September 19, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we record live from Denmark on the way from Orhus to Copenhagen, we chat about the Roku Engineering Symposium that we attended the previous day, including a plethora of other random topics. This episode is pure chaos.
他们在那里运行 Linux，但内存环境有限。基本上，Roku 的每个人都听 ADSP。猎豹，就像，你知道的，去追逐这只黑斑羚。下次买特斯拉吧，伙计们。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 254 期，录制于 2025 年 9 月 19 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 在从奥胡斯前往哥本哈根的路上进行现场录制，我们聊了聊前一天参加的 Roku 工程研讨会，以及其他各种各样的随机话题。这一期节目纯属混乱。
We're back, folks, on the beautiful roads of Denmark. Hello to our Danish listeners. We have acquired a bunch of information about the countries of Europe and Scandinavia. Tell us why are we in a car, Bryce? This was not planned. This was not planned. We were going to take a train like, you know,
我们回来了，伙计们，在丹麦美丽的公路上。向我们的丹麦听众问好。我们已经获取了关于欧洲和斯堪的纳维亚国家的大量信息。告诉我们，Bryce，我们为什么在车里？这不在计划之内。这不在计划之内。我们本来打算坐火车的，你知道的，
the European way. We were going to take a train from our hosts where we currently are to Copenhagen today. We'll explain why in a moment. But the important thing is that we got on the train. Now, Connor's phone kind of died overnight. So there was
欧洲人的方式。我们本来打算今天从我们目前所在的住处坐火车去哥本哈根。我们稍后会解释原因。但重要的是我们上了火车。现在，Connor 的手机昨晚没电了。所以当时
there was some question about whether she was going to make it in time because I was about to go to the train station, couldn't reach Connor, had to go knock on his door, and then he woke up and I was like, well, I'm going to go to the train station, you meet me there, but he made it in time, train left the station, and then it stopped about 10 minutes later, and then it waited there for about 40 to 50 minutes, and then they told us that there was some problem with the train track,
当时有人质疑她是否能及时赶到，因为我正要出发去火车站，联系不上 Connor，不得不去敲他的门，然后他醒了，我说，好吧，我要去火车站，你在那儿跟我会合，但他及时赶到了，火车离开了车站，然后大约 10 分钟后停了下来，接着在那里等了大约 40 到 50 分钟，然后他们告诉我们铁轨出了点问题，
and that we had to go back to Arjos, which we did, and then they told us to get off the train, at which point I said, you know what, I think we should seek an alternate mode of transportation. So now we have a rental car. This is accurate. Everything Bryce has said is true. I would have missed the train if he had not woken me up.
我们必须回到奥胡斯，我们照做了，然后他们让我们下车，当时我说，你知道吗，我想我们应该寻找另一种交通方式。所以现在我们租了一辆车。这是准确的。Bryce 所说的一切都是真的。如果他没叫醒我，我就错过火车了。
But that's because I was out late with the wonderful people of Roku. Shout out to Yaspur, Andreas, Jonas. There's a bunch of folks we met. And we had a fantastic time at the Roku's, symposium. If you are in or near Denmark next year, I think this is an annual thing that they do. It says on one of the websites that it's an invite only event, but invite only means those that are invited and the public is invited. So you can go. We met a bunch of folks that were not at Roku. Anyways, it was a great event. And we were out late. I mean, you left at 11,
但那是因为我和 Roku 的那些很棒的人出去玩得太晚了。向 Yaspur、Andreas、Jonas 致敬。我们遇到了很多人。我们在 Roku 的研讨会上度过了一段美妙的时光。如果你明年在丹麦或附近，我想这是他们每年都会举办的活动。其中一个网站上说这是一个仅限受邀者参加的活动，但仅限受邀者意味着受邀者和公众都可以参加。所以你可以去。我们遇到了很多不是 Roku 的人。总之，这是一次很棒的活动。我们出去得很晚。我是说，你 11 点就走了，
but I was out until 1. And then I had to call my beautiful fiancé and talk to her. And so I didn't get to sleep until two. And I did plug my phone in and set an alarm, but I did not correctly put the hotel card in the electricity slot. And so everything died. But thankfully, Bryce woke me up at 801. Our train was at 815. I quickly packed, stopped off at a 7-Eleven to get a Coke zero, as one does. And I had four minutes to spare, which is pretty impressive. Ten minutes to pack, head out the door, pick up a beverage. And now we are, we're on the highway. The E45.
但我一直待到 1 点。然后我不得不给我的未婚妻打电话和她聊天。所以我直到两点才睡着。我确实给手机充了电并设了闹钟，但我没有正确地把酒店房卡插进取电槽。所以一切都断电了。但谢天谢地，Bryce 在 8 点 01 分叫醒了我。我们的火车是 8 点 15 分的。我迅速收拾好行李，在 7-Eleven 停下来买了一瓶零度可乐，就像人们常做的那样。我还有四分钟的空余时间，这相当令人印象深刻。十分钟打包，出门，买饮料。现在我们已经在高速公路上了。E45 公路。
E45, beautiful Denmark. We love Denmark. And what else is there to say about our adventures this morning? Well, I don't know if there's anything to say about our adventures this morning, but, so we both gave talks at the Roku Engineering Symposium yesterday. And I gave a talk on modern Kuda C++ plus and kind of gave a talk on postmodern and C++. But there was also a talk
E45，美丽的丹麦。我们爱丹麦。关于我们今天早上的冒险还有什么可说的吗？嗯，我不知道关于我们今天早上的冒险还有什么可说的，但是，我们俩昨天都在 Roku 工程研讨会上做了演讲。我做了一个关于现代 CUDA C++ 的演讲，Kindle 做了一个关于后现代和 C++ 的演讲。但还有一个演讲
by two Roku engineers on like optimizing for binary size, obviously important for embedded programmers. And they talked a little bit about Roasted, which is their internal, like, core library. And
由两位 Roku 工程师主讲，关于优化二进制大小，这对嵌入式程序员来说显然很重要。他们还谈到了 Roasted，这是他们的内部核心库。而且
maybe you can give some of your thoughts. I thought the talks were fantastic. They used the morph transition very beautiful. I love it. I don't see it often, but I do see it more frequently now, and it was co-presented by Andreas and Jonas. And yeah, I was talking to them afterwards asking if we were able to mention the, so it's Roe Stood as RO and then STD, so a little play on the stood namespace. And I was asking them if we could mention it, and they said certain aspects of not what they
也许你可以分享一下你的想法。我觉得演讲非常精彩。他们使用了变形过渡，非常漂亮。我很少见到它，但我现在见得更多了，这是由 Andreas 和 Jonas 共同呈现的。是的，我事后和他们交谈，问我们是否可以提到它，所以它是 Roe Stood，即 RO 加上 STD，算是对 std 命名空间的一个小调侃。我问他们是否可以提到它，他们说不是他们昨天谈论的某些方面，所以我不能深入细节，但他们说，他们基本上是对标准库的扩展，其他方面是开源的。所以，当我在几周后剪辑这期节目时，我会去 GitHub 上找到它，并在节目笔记中贴上链接，供感兴趣的人参考。是的，这是一次很棒的演讲。而且，我当时在想所有不同的企业标准库。有 BSL，彭博标准库。有 ASL，Adobe 标准库。
talked about yesterday, so I can't really go into details there, but they said, other aspects of their basically extension of the standard library is open source. So I will, when I'm editing this in a couple weeks, I will find that on GitHub, post a link in the show notes for those that are interested. And, yeah, it was a great talk. And I was, yeah, I was trying to think of all the different corporate, you know, standard libraries. There's the BSL, the Bloomberg standard library. There's the ASL, the Adobe standard libraries.
我知道 EA，我想大多数人都熟悉这家游戏公司，EA，it's in the game，不管是什么。EA Sports，it's in the game。我会去找到那个实际的片段，因为任何玩过 NHL 或 FIFA 游戏且年龄与我们差不多的人都会记得童年时的这段话。总之，他们有 EA STL，但我从未听说过 Roasted。还有，你知道这一点，我不知道。我不知道 Roku 是 Netflix 的衍生公司，
I know that EA, which is, I think most people are familiar with a games company, EA, it's in the game, whatever it is. EA Sports, it's in the game. I'll go find the actual clip, because anyone that's played like, you know, the NHL or FIFA games that are roughly plus or minus our age will remember that from their childhood. Anyways, there's a bunch of, they had the EA STL, but I had never heard of Roasted. Also, too, I, you knew this, I did not. I did not know that Roku was a spinoff of Netflix,
它最初就像一个团队，或者是在 Netflix 内部。我不知道这一点。你知道吗？你知道 Roku 的历史吗？我知道那部分，因为我用 Roku 很久了，因为我们家里真的没有任何苹果设备。所以如果我想看 Apple TV，我无法在我的平板电脑、手机或任何东西上，或者在我的 Android TV 上观看，
and it was initially like a team or it was inside of Netflix. I did not know that. Do you know that? Do you know the history of Roku? I knew about that part of it because I've had like a Roku for a long time because we don't really have any Apple devices in my household. And so if I want to watch Apple TV, I can't do it on my, like, tablet or my phone or anything or on my Android TV,
但 Roku 设备上有一个 Apple TV 频道，这就是我们目前拥有并使用 Roku 的原因。实际上，我想我们目前使用的 Roku 是几年前在 C++ 会议上给我的。是什么来着？C++ 和 C 会议太多了。我向 Phil Nash 道歉。我知道你偶尔会听。
but there is an Apple TV channel on the Roku device, which is why we currently have and use a Roku. Actually, I think the current Roku that we use is one that was given to me at C++ by the C, a couple years ago, on the C. What is it? There's too many C++ and C conferences. I apologize to Phil Nash. I know that you listen every once in a while.
如果你正在听这个，我代表 Bryce 向你道歉。是 C++ on Sea。我其实不知道他们为什么去掉了……我确实认为那些创造了 C++ on Sea 的荷兰人做对了，没有保持对称。因为我的意思是，C++ on the sea，
If you're listening to this, I apologize on Bryce's behalf. It is C++ on C. I actually don't know why they dropped the... I do think that the Dutch that have created C++ under the sea, they did the right thing by not being symmetric. Because I mean, C++ on the sea,
老实说。它比 on C 听起来更好听。我其实不知道为什么没有 the。你知道为什么没有 the 吗？我不知道。我们可以问 Phil。我相信有什么诗意的理由，或者它是我们不知道的某个东西的引用。
let's be honest. It's got a better ring to it than on C. And I actually, I don't know why there's no the. Do you know why there's no the? I don't know. We can ask Phil. I'm sure there's some poetic reason or it's a reference to something that we don't know.
我想也许这是一个双关语，但它就像 C-plus-plus on C，因为，你知道，C-S-E-A 听起来像 C，那个编程语言的名字，所以这有可能。是的，但一个 the 不会妨碍这一点。不，因为，如果你说，比如 C-plus on C，就好像，你不会说 the C，当你谈论 C 编程语言时，你知道，你可能会说 the C 编程语言，但如果你只是提到它，你只说 C，C，或者 the C 编程语言。但另一件有趣的事情是与 Roku 的人们交谈，我们交谈的大多数人，我想我们应该提供一点背景，所以 Roku 制造了这些被称为播放器的小东西，你可以把它们插到电视上，让你像
I think maybe it's a play on words, but it's like C-plus-plus on C because, you know, C-S-E-A sounds like C-S-E-A sounds like C, the letter, the name of the programming language, so that's possible. Yeah, but a the-the doesn't obstruct that. No, because, like, if you said, like, C-plus on C as if, like, you don't say, like, the C, when you're talking about the C programming language, you know, you might say the C programming language, but if you're just, you know, referring to it, you just say C, C, or the C-C programming language. but the other thing that was interesting talking with the Roku folks and most of the people that we talked I guess we should give a little bit of context so Roku makes these little things that are called players that you can plug into your TV that let you like
它是一个流媒体播放器，他们现在也制造自己的电视，最接近的类比是像 Apple TV 或我们的客人 Apple TV 曾经制造的设备，或者 Android TV。所以基本上他们制造像智能电视，智能电视，
it's a streaming media player they also now make their own TVs sort of a the closest analogy would be something like the Apple TV or the our guest Apple TV used to make a device or the Android TVs So it's basically they make like a smart TV, smart TVs,
然后他们制造你可以插到电视上的设备，把它变成智能电视。所以我们交谈的很多人都是从事电视软件工作的人。这显然是一个嵌入式平台。它不像，它不像，你知道，微控制器。他们在那里运行 Linux，但这是一个内存受限的环境。有趣的是，尽管他们支持他们的一些最旧的设备，他们仍然支持 10 年前的设备，他们使用现代 C++，当我问他们时，他们说他们几乎积极地更新到某种最新的标准和最新的编译器，并部署到他们的一些最旧的设备上。我觉得这非常有趣，因为许多有这样长期支持周期的人，他们不能使用更现代的 C++，因为他们受到旧设备操作系统限制的约束。
and then they make devices that you can plug into your TV to turn it into a smart TV. And so a lot of the people we talk to were there people who work on the software that goes into the TVs. And this is obviously an embedded platform. It's not like, it's not like a, you know, a microcontroller. They're running Linux there, but it's a limited memory environment. And interestingly, despite the fact that they support back to some of their oldest devices, devices, that they're still supporting devices that are like 10 years old, they use modern C++ and they, when I asked them, they said that they pretty much they aggressively update to sort of the latest standards and latest compilers, and they deploy back to some of their oldest devices. And I thought that was really interesting because a lot of people who have like a long support cycle like that, they can't use more modern C++ because they're constrained by the operating system limitations on the older devices.
但在 Roku 的情况下，这是一个封闭的生态系统，他们控制着操作系统和一切，所以他们可以推送任何最新操作系统和整个堆栈的更新。这让他们能够，你知道，保持领先并非常现代。我觉得这非常有趣。我认为如果能看到更多关于他们如何处理现代 C++ 嵌入式开发的演讲会很棒。是的，我们和几个人交谈过，
But in Roku's case, it's a closed ecosystem where they control the OS and everything, so they can push an update of whatever the latest OS and their entire stack. And that lets them be, you know, live it head and be very modern. I thought that was very interesting. And I think it would be great to see more talks from them about how they handle. embedded development with modern C++. Yeah, we talked to a few people
他们说他们在一些不同的 C++ 会议上做过演讲。所以我去找到那些链接，它们会出现在节目笔记中。我想我没在 C++ 会议上见过 Roku 的演讲，但互联网上有成百上千的视频，所以我并不惊讶他们有。
that said that they had given conference talks at some different C++ plus conferences. So I will go find those links and they will be in the show notes. I don't think I've seen a Roku talk at a C++ conference, but there are hundreds of videos out on the internet, so I'm not surprised that they have.
是的，和 Roku 的人们交谈很有趣。我们还和几位应届毕业生交谈，他们说现在的招聘环境相当艰难，相当惨淡。我，你知道，我听说过一些故事，但我没有直接从任何大学生那里听说过，他们说从最近的毕业生来看，他们说什么，75% 的人没有找到工作。
And yeah, it was interesting talking with the Roku folks. We also, we talked to a couple recent graduates and they were saying that the hiring landscape right now, it's pretty rough, pretty bleak. I, you know, I'd heard stories, but I had not directly heard from any university students, and they were saying that from the most recent graduates, what did they say, 75% have not found jobs.
所以，是的，不太好，不太好。是的，是的，它是，所以我们交谈的那个人，他叫什么名字？哦，是 Ryan，Ryan。他在英国上学，获得了计算机科学本科学位，他在 Roku 找到了一份工作，他说他在 Roku 实习过，基本上 Roku 的所有新员工，比如新大学毕业生，都是有过实习经历的人。这当然是我的经验，作为刚出校门的初级工程师，获得录用的唯一真正可靠的方法就是有过实习经历。
So, yeah, not great, not great. Yeah, yeah, it was, so the fellow we spoke to, what was his name? Oh, it was Ryan, Ryan. He went school in the UK, got a CS undergraduate degree, and he got a job at Roku, and he'd said that he had an internship at Roku, and that basically all of the new hires at Roku, like the new college grad hires, have been people who had had internships. And that's certainly been my experience, that the only real, reliable way to get hired as, you know, a junior engineer coming out of college is to have had internships.
但他说他 75% 的同学在科技行业没有工作，我不记得他说他们正在做什么，如果他们正在寻找其他行业，或者如果他们正在考虑回学校，但这确实是一个艰难的环境，即使是获得实习机会，我认为也变得越来越难。什么是，好吧，我看到了一些，我以为我看到了一些路杀，这总是让我非常难过，但我其实不认为那是
but yeah he said like 75% of his classmates did not have a job in tech and I don't remember what he said that they were doing if they were looking at other industries or if they were looking at going back to school but it is a tough a tough environment right now and even getting the internships I think is getting harder what was the well I saw some I thought I saw some roadkill which always makes me very sad but I don't actually think it was
我认为那是一些看起来像大兔子的垃圾，但并不是。有，所以 Ramona 和我刚在非洲进行了一次狩猎旅行，你知道，Ramona 真的很喜欢动物，我们看到了两次不同的场合，你知道，大型猫科动物在捕猎其他东西，Ramona 对此感到非常受创，就像，为什么，为什么我们不能和平共处，每个人都可以吃，吃植物？幸运的是，我认为为了她的心理健康，在这两种情况下，大型猫科动物都没有抓到猎物。我的意思是，那并没有让我难过，因为那只是生态系统以它应该的方式运作。路杀让我心碎，因为
I think it was some garbage that looked like a large rabbit, but it was not. There was, so Ramona and I were just on a safari in Africa, and, you know, Ramona really loves animals, and we saw two different, there were two different occasions where, you know, big cats were hunting something else, and Ramona was very traumatized the way that's just like, why can't, why can't we just all live together in peace and everybody can eat, eat the plants? And fortunately, I think for her mental well-being in both cases, the big cap did not catch the prey. I mean, that's, that doesn't make me sad because that's just the ecosystem working the way it should. Roadkill breaks my heart because
这就像人类……你本来会，我想，被这个困扰，因为周围有太多的狩猎车辆，我们正在观看这只像，呃，猎豹，像，你知道，去追逐这只黑斑羚，然后有一小群像疣猪，带着这四只可爱的小疣猪宝宝，但那里有，那里有太多的狩猎车辆，它们把猎物围住了，所以很明显，狩猎旅行的人在某种程度上干扰了正在发生的事情，但幸运的是，那只小黑斑羚逃脱了，Ramona 非常担心
it's like humans that are... You would have, I think, been bothered by this because they were so many safari vehicles around we were watching this like uh cheetah like like uh you know going after this uh impala and then there was this little family of like wurt hogs with these four cute little baby warthogs but there were all there were so many safari vehicles there they sort of had boxed in the prey um and so it was like pretty clear that like the the people on safari were kind of interfering with what was what was happening there but uh but fortunately the uh the little impala got away and Ramona was very worried
疣猪和疣猪宝宝，但当猎豹开始追逐那只黑斑羚时，疣猪妈妈开始冲向那只猎豹，而猎豹
about the Wirthawk and the Wirthawk Davies but when the Cheetah started going after that in Pala the Wirthog Mama started charging that cheetah and the cheetah
就像，我不会惹这只疣猪，因为疣猪，它们在非洲没有得到赞誉，但它们，你知道
was like I am not messing with this this whirthog because the wurt hogs they don't get credit in Africa but they you know
很多人被野猪杀死，它们基本上只是野猪的稍微小一点的版本，总之这是一个大的
a lot of people get killed by by wild boars and they're basically just like a slightly smaller version of a wild boar anyways this is a big
只是为了毕业。那么我们为什么要前往哥本哈根？我们要去哥本哈根。好吧，首先，在我们谈论下一站之前，还有几件事要谈论，好吧，我们有了地理统计数据，而且，我们还在一辆 Polestar 里。Polestar 在我们的一期特斯拉节目中被提到过。我们有我们的特斯拉还是不特斯拉。
just to graduate And so why are we going to Copenhagen? We're going to Copenhagen. Well, first off, before we talk about our next stop, a couple more things to talk about the, well, we got the geographic stats, but also, too, we are in a poll star. Polestar were mentioned on one of our Tesla episodes. We had our to Tesla or not to Tesla.
或者我想，我不记得它们叫什么了。但总之，我们有两期不同的节目，我在讨论是否要买特斯拉。对于热心的听众，你们已经有了更新。我们最终买了一辆 2025 款丰田普锐斯插电式混合动力车。混合动力车，这是一辆很棒的车，有一些小问题，但总的来说，我的意思是，我确实有点后悔没有买特斯拉，但我们在 Polestar 里。我开了，什么，到目前为止 50 公里，差不多这样，我的评价是，呃，我的意思是，你说你喜欢 Polestar，但这是我的问题。我会说，你知道，当我谈论买特斯拉时，我开过很多车，但现在我开得更多了。所以我喜欢认为自己是一个知情的专家
Or I think, I can't remember what they were called. But anyways, we had two different episodes where I was debating it into Tesla. For the avid listener, you've had the update. We ended up buying a 2025 Toyota Piraeus plug-in hybrid. The hybrid, it's a great car, a couple issues with it, but overall, I mean, I do regret a little bit not getting a Tesla, but we're at Polestar. I've driven, what, 50 kilometers so far, something like that, and my review is, uh, I mean, you said that you like Polestar, but here's my issues. And I will say, you know, back when I was talking about getting a Tesla, I had driven a lot, but now I drive a lot more. and so I like to consider myself an informed expert
以及我以前不会注意到的事情，只有一个风扇对着我的脸，我需要，你知道，我需要不断地，最近我做出的最好的投资之一是一个安静的 Palanis 风扇，亚马逊上 100 美元。我不确定我是否提到过，Chima 和我在我们的公寓里有温度战争
and things that I would not have noticed before there's only one fan pointing at my face I need to have you know I need to be constantly one of the best investments recently that I made was in a quiet Palanis fan was 100 bucks on Amazon I'm not sure if I've ever mentioned that Chima and I we have temperature wars back in our condo
她总是会把空调调到 23.5 或 24，或者上帝保佑，她直接把它关了，呃，我从跑步回来，我已经像在流血一样出汗，感觉就像在桑拿房里，然后我总是把它调到 22，基本上我们就是来回改变温度，你知道这有点像个笑话，呃，你知道，如果你愿意的话，这是一种爱的语言，但后来我真的决定我无法忍受这种 23.5 24 的胡说八道，所以我买了一个安静的风扇，这改变了游戏规则。如果你像我一样怕热，伙计们，而且你和你的伴侣在进行温度战争，或者你只是想节省空调费，给自己买个风扇。总之，你必须，你必须在开车时有风吹在脸上，
and she would always be switching the AC to 23.5 or 24 or god help us she just turned it off and uh i'd come back from a run and i'm already like bleeding sweat and it feels like a sauna in the place and then i would always change it to 22 and that was basically we'd just go back and forth changing the temperature and you know it's kind of a joke uh you know a love language if you will and but then i i really decided that i couldn't handle this 23.5 24 nonsense so i bought a quiet fan it has been a game changer if you run hot blood at folks and you're in a temperature wars with your partner or you just want to save money on AC get yourself a fan who anyways you got to have you got to have the wind in your face when
来让自己凉快下来，他们只有一个小风扇在左边，而我的丰田，它到处都是风扇，我可以把我的两个风扇，还有中间 Chima 的风扇指向我，我有三个风扇，而这个，它就像，它是什么，它指向车顶，指向挡风玻璃，而且，我的意思是，我知道我们不喜欢 Elon，因为很多原因，但我无法理解为什么世界上每一辆该死的车都不复制他们的手机充电器，像，模型。那很简单，伙计们。你想要两个不同的充电器，一个给你，一个给你的伴侣，而且你不想要一个插槽。这就是普锐斯有的。它是一个插槽，所以，就像，这很荒谬，而且它还会让手机过热。什么是插槽？什么是插槽？所以，想象一下，像一个小
you're driving a car to cool cool yourself down and they've got only one tiny fan on the left whereas my Toyota it's got fans all over the place I can point my two fans and also Shima's fan in the middle at me I got three fans and this one it's like what is it it's pointed at the roof at the windshield and also too I mean I know we don't like Elon, because of many reasons, but I don't understand why every goddamn car in the world does not copy their cell phone charger, like, model. In that is real simple, folks. You want two different chargers, one for you and your partner, and you don't want a slot. That's what the Prius has. It's a slot, so, like, it's ridiculous, and also it overheats the phones. What is a slot? What is a slot? So, picture, like, a little.
小烤面包机，你把一片面包放进去。就像，用一个你可以把手机放进去的单一东西代替烤面包机。这就是他们充电的方式。所以不是一个你可以放手机的地方，你把它放进去，这显然是不方便且荒谬的。但他们试图节省空间什么的。我看到一些东西说，哦，这是一个很棒的设计。它节省空间。闭嘴。你不需要节省空间。你的手机是一个延伸。我们都是半机械人。你需要能够看到它。Bryce，给我们描述一下 Polestar 是怎么做的。好吧，Polestar 有一个小的，像在仪表盘上，呃，在控制台上，中控台有一个小插槽，你可以放一个手机，然后在它右边旁边有
little toaster that you put a slice of bread in. It's like, replace the toaster with just a single thing that you can drop your cell phone in. And that's how they charge it. So instead of somewhere where you lay your phone, you drop it in, which obviously is inconvenient and just ridiculous. But they're trying to save space or whatever. I saw something that was like, oh, this is a great design. It saves space. Shut up. You don't need to save space. Your cell phone is an extension. We're all cyborgs. You need to be able to see it. Describe to us, Bryce, what the pole store does. well the pole star has one little like on the on the dash uh on the console the the center console there's like one little slot where you can put one phone and then on the right next to it there's
好吧，这没用，这没用，它简单多了，它和特斯拉一模一样，除了他们反转了它的朝向。为什么你会，为什么你会？所以就像特斯拉的，它就像特斯拉的，你知道，一个面向你的倾斜仪表盘。Polestar 已经把那个反转了。所以它是一个倾斜的仪表盘，但它背对着你。所以你只能看到你手机的屁股。你在做什么，Polestar？你在做什么？老实说，每一辆车，当我研究所有不同的电动汽车时，它们对如何处理手机都有一些愚蠢的看法。直接复制特斯拉。它甚至不像，你知道，这不是你需要创新的地方。可能他们做了一些研究说，哦，如果你不显示手机屏幕，
all right this didn't work this didn't work it's a lot simpler it's exactly like the Tesla except they reversed the way it's facing why would you why would you so like a Tesla's it's like a Tesla's like, you know, a slanted dash that's facing you. The Polestar has like inverted that. So it's a slanted dash, but it's facing away from you. So all you can see is the butt of your cell phone. What are you doing, Polestar? What are you doing? And honestly, every single car, when I looked into all the different electric vehicles, they all have some stupid take on how to do cell phone. Just copy Tesla. It's not, it's not even like, you know, this is not somewhere you need to be novel. And probably they did some study that says, oh, if you don't show the cell phone screen,
更安全。猜猜怎么着？那很荒谬。我需要看到我的，我需要看到我手机上的电量百分比。而且，它现在在充电吗？我知道当我检查时，我知道当我检查它时，它确实点亮了屏幕并给了你一个小数字，但就像，我现在看不出屏幕是否打开，或者它是否有小百分比的东西。总之，Polestar，这步棋走得有点大。而且，这辆车的方向盘到油门和刹车踏板的距离最短，这意味着，就像，我的膝盖被挤压了，而且我坐得很靠后，所以，就像，这非常尴尬，总之，你在做什么，Polestar？
safer. Guess what? That's ridiculous. I need to see my, I need to see the percentage of the charge on my phone. And also, is it charging right now? I know that when I checked, I know that when I checked it, it did light up the screen and give you a little number, but like, I can't see right now if, if the screen is on or if it has a little percentage thing. Anyways, Polestar, it's a big swing to miss. And also, too, this car has the shortest distance from the steering wheel to the accelerator and brake pedals, which means that, like, my knees, are crunched up, and I'm pretty far back, and so, like, it's very awkward to, anyways, what are you doing, Polestar?
我，呃，Shima 的表弟有一辆 Polestar，他给出了极高的评价，说它比特斯拉好得多。而且，我不喜欢 Elon，伙计们，我没有买特斯拉，但老实说，所有的星星和迹象都指向特斯拉。他们有 FSD，这就是我们最初想要它的原因，而且，呃，现在，我生命中的挚爱必须开车。她不喜欢开车。她想让机器人来开车。
I, uh, Shima's cousin has a Polestar, and he has got rave reviews and says it's way better than Tesla. And, like, I don't like Elon, folks, and I didn't buy Tesla, but honestly, all stars and signs point towards Tesla. They got FSD, that's the reason we wanted in the first place, and, uh, now, uh, the love of my life has to drive the car. She doesn't like driving. She wanted the robots to do the driving.
让我们把艺术和艺术家分开，下次买特斯拉吧，伙计们，这就是我对 Polestar 和特斯拉的一点看法。敬请期待三个月后我下一次有车评的时候，哦上帝，我甚至要去哪里
let's just separate the art from the artist and buy Tesla next time folks that's my that's my little bit on Polestar's and Tesla's stay tuned in three months for the next time I've got a car review oh god where is I going to even go there
这么多，这么多，这么多事情，哦上帝，有什么我要说的，我要说什么，好吧，你喜欢 Polestar，所以我不知道，也许你在你的咆哮中有什么积极的东西。我的意思是，我租，哦不，我知道我要说什么，所以我的我的
so many so many so many things oh god there was something I was going to say what was I going to say well you like Polestar so I don't know maybe you had something positive in your rents I mean I rent oh no I know what I was going to say so my my be
关于现代汽车设计或后现代汽车设计是汽车，两件事，两个 UI 东西。首先，太多的触摸屏，我们需要触觉界面。哦，那是，所以那是关于，好吧，可爱的事情之一。我对普锐斯有抱怨，但普锐斯的屏幕，它太小了。我们确实，我们买了 XSE，它从 8 英寸屏幕变成了 12 英寸屏幕，但它有点像那种水平的，但在屏幕下面，或者它是，它是按钮下面吗？他们有一堆按钮，这非常好。所以当你摆弄基本上所有的汽车控制时，仍然是物理按钮，
with modern car design or postmodern car design is cars, two things, two UI things. First of all, too many touch screens, we need tactile interfaces. Oh, that's, so that's the lovely thing about the, well, one of the lovely things. I have complaints about the Prius, but the Prius's screen, it is too small. We did, we got the XSE, which goes from an 8-inch screen to a 12-inch screen, but it's kind of one of those horizontal ones, but underneath the screen, or is it, is it underneath the buttons? they have a bunch of buttons that is very nice. So when you are messing around with basically all the car controls are still physical buttons,
它唯一显示给你的就是你的播客播放器和谷歌地图。仅此而已。所以这相当不错，因为你开车时确实需要。你不想摆弄像，你知道，这是关于特斯拉的抱怨之一，比如对于某些设置。你必须按四次。这就是你最终发生车祸的原因，就像试图导航到某个菜单，这样你就可以改变某些东西。在未来，我们只是对汽车说话，因为它将是一个有知觉的，你知道，系统。
the only thing it shows you is like your podcast player and Google Maps. And that's it. So that is quite nice because you do when you're driving. You don't want to be footsing around with like, you know, that's one of the complaints about the Tesla is like for certain settings. You have to hit four times. That is how you end up in a car accident is like trying to navigate to some menu so you can change something. In the future, we just speak to the car because it'll be a sentient, you know, system.
你知道，你最终发生车祸的另一种方式是当你不知道如何使用车里的换挡器时，因为汽车公司决定，出于某种原因，拥有一个你在中控台中物理移动的操纵杆的简单直观界面，不，那需要被重新发明。我们，我和我爸爸在几年前我们在优胜美地时租了这辆梅赛德斯，换挡器在方向盘上，这还不算太糟，但，就像，它的设计方式，就像，每次我们必须把车挂入倒档时，我们几乎都会撞到什么东西。然后有一次，Ramona 和我租了一些，我想是通用汽车，像 SUV，换挡器
You know, how else you end up in a car? car accident is when you don't know how to use the shifter in the car because the car company has decided that for some reason the very simple intuitive interface of having a stick that you physically shift around that's in the center console no that needs to be reinvented we've we were in my dad and i rented uh this mercedes when we were in yosemite a couple years ago where the shifter was on the steering wheel, which isn't so bad, but, like, the way that it was designed, like, every time we had to put the car into reverse, we would nearly hit something. And then one time, Romona and I rented some, I think it was a GM, like, SUV, where the shifter
就像，它在后视镜所在的地方。所以你必须，就像，伸手按一个按钮来换挡。就像，为什么，为什么我们要重新发明这个？只要放一个操纵杆，一个物理操纵杆，在中控台。这就是你所需要的。我们不需要重新发明这个。重大的安全问题。但是的，你要做什么？总之，这些是我们的汽车想法。是的，然后我需要提到的另一件事，我刚刚调大了，说到风，我刚刚把它调大了一点。所以希望，希望这没有破坏收听体验。我们学到的另一件事，
was, like, it was up on where the, like, the rear view mirror would be. And so you had to, like, reach up and press a button to shift. It's like, why, why are we reinventing this? Just put a stick, a physical stick, in the center. console. That's all you need. We didn't need to reinvent this. Major safety thing. But yeah, what are you going to do? Anyways, those are our car thoughts. Yes, and then the other thing I needed to mention, and I just turned up the, speaking of the wind, I just turned it up a little bit. So hopefully, hopefully this isn't ruining the listening experience. The other thing we learned,
它是什么，是 Andreas 提到的 Roku 的演讲者之一。他提到了，显然，这有点像个玩笑。但他基本上说 Roku 的每个人都听 ADSP。哦对了，记得我还有一件事要补充，与 Roku 无关。这是一个大新闻，对伙计们来说是大新闻。他说，他开玩笑说每个人都听这个播客。我就想，嗯，这很有趣。因为来到丹麦以来，第一次来丹麦，美丽的国家，
what was it, was it, Andreas mentioned one of the speakers at Roku. He mentioned, obviously, it was a bit of a joke. But he said, basically everyone at Roku listens to ADSP. Oh yeah, and remember I got another thing to add that not to do with Roku. That is a big news, big news for folks. He said, he joked that everyone listened to the podcast. And I was like, huh, that's interesting. Because since coming to Denmark, first time in Denmark, beautiful country,
了解到人口不到六百万。所以就人口而言，它相当小。它稍微小一点。我就想，我想知道，你知道，丹麦在哪里。在排名中。所以我查看了我们使用的网站上的统计数据。丹麦排名第 11 位，这相当高，
learned that the population is just under six million. So it's a rather small, in terms of population. It's a little bit smaller. And I was like, I wonder, you know, where Denmark is. in the rankings. So I hit up the stats on our website that we use. And Denmark is ranked number 11th, which is pretty high up there,
超出了它的重量级。然后我去问 Gemini，我复制了前 50 个国家，并要求它做一个人均计算。而丹麦，丹麦的美好、美丽的人民，人均下载量和收听率是第二名。所以我们只想向我们的丹麦听众致敬。
punching above its weight. And then I went and asked Gemini, I copied the top 50 countries and asked it to do a per capita calculation. And Denmark, the wonderful, beautiful people of Denmark, per capita are the number two country in terms of downloads and listenership. So we'd just like to shout out to our Danish listeners.
而且，我的意思是，Bryce 已经知道了。如果他不知道，我会玩个小游戏。但前五名，相当令人惊讶，相当令人惊讶。因为显然，或者也许不是显然，第一名是美国，但，你知道，他们是世界前五大人口国。第一名是瑞典。我们爱瑞典人民。我们向我们的瑞典听众致敬。
And, I mean, Bryce already knows this. If he didn't, I would play a little game. But the top five, quite surprising, quite surprising. Because obviously, or maybe not obviously, number one is the United States, but, you know, they're top five populist country in the world. Number one is Sweden. We love the people of Sweden. And we shout out to our Swedish listeners.
第二名是丹麦。第三名是挪威，我们这次旅行稍后会去那里。第四名是瑞士。第五名是芬兰。所以人均收听率前五名中的所有四个国家都是斯堪的纳维亚国家。所以我不知道那里发生了什么，如果我们有一些推广者。而且我认为我们并不经常要求评分或评论，
And number two is Denmark. Number three is Norway, where we're headed later in this trip. Number four is Switzerland. And number five is Finland. So all four of the top five countries by per capita. by listenership are the Scandinavian country. So I'm not sure what's going on there if we've got some promoters. And I think we don't really ask for ratings or reviews that often,
你知道，也许每 100 期一次。但我认为我们应该开始做的是在每年年底，或者也许每六个月，我们会做一个播客，统计数据，排名之类的事情。所以显然，你知道，丹麦人和瑞典人，他们有一段历史。所以我很确定丹麦，你知道，丹麦人民想成为第一。所以我们不是在要求评论。但如果你想成为第一，丹麦，你必须专门告诉你的丹麦邻居关于这个播客。但不要告诉任何住在瑞典的人。
you know, once maybe every 100 episode. But I think what we should start doing is at the end of every year, or maybe every six months, we will do a podcast, statistics, you know, rankings kind of thing. And so obviously, you know, the Danish and the Swedish, they've got a history. And so I'm pretty sure Denmark, you know, the people of Denmark want to be number one. So we're not asking for reviews. But if you'd like to be number one, Denmark, you've got to specifically tell your Danish neighbors about the pod. But not any of them who live in Sweden.
没错。好吧，我不知道是否有任何丹麦人住在瑞典。而且，如果你在美国有朋友，你知道，那没有帮助，因为你需要是，这不是按你的国籍。这是你从哪里下载的。如果你碰巧去瑞典一天，确保你已经下载了你的播客，因为如果我们在周五发布一期播客，而你碰巧在进行一日访问，但如果你这样做，确保你在过水、过池塘之前下载了播客，我们会看看芬兰能否，你知道，进入前四名并取代
Exactly. Well, I don't know if there's any Danish people living in Sweden. And also, too, if you've got friends in the States, you know, that doesn't help because you need to be, it's not by your nationality. It's where you're downloading from. And if you happen to be going to Sweden for the day, make sure you got your podcast download it already because if it what if we drop a pod on Friday and you happen to be doing some day visit but if you're doing that make sure you got the pod download before you go across the water across the pond and we'll see can Finland you know break into the top four and unseat
瑞士，总之我觉得那是，呃，我根本不知道，我不经常看统计数据，但我觉得这很有趣，呃，当 Andreas 提到 Roku 的很多人都在听，所以我当时想，我想知道，我查了一下，就在那里，第二名，还有斯洛文尼亚，我想斯洛文尼亚不在前 10 名，但人均，他们在前 10 名。我想他们排名第八。向斯洛文尼亚致敬，我们仍然爱你。我意识到，就像，我们做这个播客太久了。我忘记了我们所有的滑稽动作。我们有一整个时期，每隔一期，我们就会说
Switzerland and anyways I thought that was uh and I had no idea like I don't look at the stats very often but I thought it was interesting uh when Andreas mentioned that a lot of folks listen at Roku and and so I was like I wonder I looked it up and there it is number two, and also Slovenia, I think Slovenia is not in the top 10, but per capita, they are in the top 10. I think they're ranked number eight. Shout out to Slovenia, we do still love you. I realize that, like, we've been doing this podcast so long. I forget about all the antics that we had. We had a whole period where every second episode, we'd say
向我们的斯洛文尼亚听众致敬，我们已经有一年或两年没那样做了。我有一个理论，你的数据洞察可能有点错误，因为你看了每个国家听众的原始数字，然后你看了人均听众，但我不太确定那是适用的指标，因为也许是这种情况，有可能瑞典、丹麦和挪威有更多的科技人员听我们的播客，而不是在其他国家，但也有可能只是这些国家的科技人员比例相对于其他国家更高。所以我想你真正需要看的不是每人口有多少人听，而是每国家科技人员人口有多少人听？你认为这些统计数据适用于我们拥有的所有 205 个国家吗，这也很令人印象深刻，当我查阅它时。我们在 205 个国家有下载量。所以我们基本上，世界上有多少个国家。我想有，我不知道，我想刚超过 200 个。我想这取决于。这取决于联合国的统计数据，但
shout out to our Slovenian listeners, and we haven't done that, probably like, in a year or two. I have a theory, that your data's insights may be a little bit mistaken because you looked at first raw numbers of listeners per country then you looked at listeners per capita but i'm not sure that that's the applicable metric because maybe it's the case it's possible that more saw tech people in uh Sweden and Denmark and Norway listen to our podcast than in other countries but it's also possible that it's just that there's a higher rate of tech people in these countries relative to other countries. So what I think you really need to look at is not how many people are listening per the
我想人体有 206 块骨头，195 个国家。所以总之，我其实不知道我们怎么有 205 个国家。我想我应该进入右侧车道。我们后面有一辆日产，那……所以我认为大多数国家可能发布
population of the country, but how many are listening per the population of people in tech in the country? You think those stats are available for all 205 countries that we have, that's pretty impressive too when I looked it up. We got downloads in 205. So we basically, how many countries are there in the world. I think that there's, I don't know, it's just over 200, I think. I guess it depends. It depends on the UN statistic, but
像按部门划分的经济细分，这可能能告诉你他们经济中科技行业的百分比，但是的，很难获得每个国家有多少人在科技行业工作的数据，但仍然，总之，这是一个有趣的理论，也许这些国家的科技人员相对于人口更多。我向丹麦和斯堪的纳维亚人民道歉，Bryce 试图夺走你们的排名，猜猜怎么着，我会问 Gemini 他们是否能做到，但我的猜测是这些统计数据不存在。
I think it's 206 bones in the body in 195. So anyways, I don't actually know how we have 205 countries. I guess I should get in the right-hand lane. We got a Nissan behind us that... So I think that most countries probably publish
但我与丹麦人民和斯堪的纳维亚人民站在一起。在我的心中和真正的排名中，你们将进入前五名。希望芬兰能跳到瑞士之上，我们可以让所有四个斯堪的纳维亚国家成为我们的前四名。但是，我的意思是，如果统计数据存在，我可以让它发生。或者更准确地说，人工智能可以让它发生。但是，是的。我们已经谈过奥胡斯在编程语言中的历史了吗？是的，我们谈了一点。
like breakdowns of their economy by sector and that might be able to tell you what percentage of their economy is in tech but yeah it's probably hard to get numbers about how many people work in tech per country but still anyway it's an interesting theory that maybe there's just more people in tech relative to the population in these countries i apologize to the people of denmark and of scandinavia bryce is trying to take away your your ranking and guess what i will ask jemini if they can do that but my guess is those stats don't exist.
而且，我也弄清楚了正确的发音。它可能还是会有点偏差，但它是 Orhus。不是 A，因为它是一个上面带有一个小圆圈的 A。我从，我从 Tom 那里理发学到的。向 Tom 致敬。Tom 肯定不听这个播客。但我本来应该在来之前理发的，没时间。所以我昨天理了发。
But I am with the people of Denmark and the people of Scandinavia. In my hearts and in the true rankings, you will be in the top five. And hopefully Finland can hop above Switzerland and we can just have all four Scandinavian countries as our top four. But, I mean, if the statistics exist, I can make it happen. Or more accurately, the AI can make it happen. But, yeah. And did we already talk about the history of Arhars in programming languages? Yeah, we did a little bit.
我们进行了长时间的交谈，他给了我一个很棒的理发。他告诉了我很多事情。其中一件事，我昨天去跑步，我偶然发现了这个非常美丽的公寓，海滨公寓。我事后查了一下，
And also, too, I have figured out the correct pronunciation. It's going to probably be a little bit off, but it's Orhus. It's not A, because it's an A with a little circle on top of it. I learned from, I got a haircut from Tom. Shout out to Tom. Tom definitely doesn't listen to the podcast. But I was supposed to get a haircut before I came, didn't have the time. So I got a haircut yesterday.
它实际上是，根据某个列表，在奥胡斯要做的第 12 件事是去看看奥胡斯，然后它是一个带斜杠的 O，或者一个带斜杠的零。你可能在想，这到底和 Tom 有什么关系？我问 Tom，我当时想，
and we had a long conversation, giving me a great haircut. He told me a bunch of stuff. And one of the things, I went for a run yesterday, and I stumbled across this really beautiful apartments, waterfront apartments. And I looked it up afterwards,
这到底是什么，那是一个词吗？那是一个字母吗？他说，哦，是的，在丹麦语中，我们有三个额外的字母。一个是上面带有一个小圆圈的 A，现在有，我想，我的意思是，我在路上见过它，但很多时候为了让事情更容易打字，他们用两个 A 代替它。所以 Orhus，即使它是一个 A，拼写为 A-A，因为它曾经是带圆圈的 A，而且它有不同的发音。
and it actually is, according to some list, the number 12 thing to do in Orhus is to go check out Orhus, and then it's a O with a slash through it, or a zero with a slash through it. And you're probably wondering, what the hell does this have to do with Tom? I asked Tom, I was like,
根据某些榜单，奥胡斯排名第12位的必做之事竟然就是去看看奥胡斯，那个名字是一个带斜杠的O，或者说带斜杠的零。你可能在想，这到底和汤姆有什么关系？我问汤姆，我说，
what the hell is this like, is that a word? Is that a letter? He's like, oh, yeah, in Danish, we've got three extra letters. One is an A with a little circle on top of it, which now has, I think, I mean, I've seen it on the road, but a lot of the times to make things easier to type, they replace that with two A's. So Orhus, even though it's an A, spelled A-A, because it used to be the A with the circle, and it has a different pronunciation.
这到底是什么，是一个词吗？还是一个字母？他说，哦，是的，在丹麦语里，我们有三个额外的字母。一个是上面带个小圆圈的A，现在我想，虽然我在路上见过它，但为了打字方便，很多时候他们会用两个A来代替。所以奥胡斯，尽管它是一个A，但拼写是A-A，因为它以前是那个带圆圈的A，而且它的发音也不同。
And then he told me that, oh, yeah, that's, I'm probably, I'm going to get my pronunciation a little long. The zero with a slash through it, or O with a slash through it, which is the O in Copenhagen, is u which by itself means island so orhus u means orhus island and anyways it was like some nicely developed stuff anyways they got three extra letters and it is the second most populous city in denmark i had no idea about that i did not i also did not know that do we know the the third should you look it up uh the third most uh cities in denmark by population i I've started using speech to text.
然后他告诉我，哦，对了，那个，我可能会，我的发音可能有点长。那个带斜杠的零，或者带斜杠的O，也就是哥本哈根里的那个O，读作u，它本身的意思是岛，所以奥胡斯u（orhus u）的意思就是奥胡斯岛。总之，那是一些开发得很好的东西，反正他们多了三个字母，而且它是丹麦人口第二多的城市，我对此一无所知。我也不知道，我们知道第三个吗？你应该查一下，呃，丹麦人口第三多的城市，我开始使用语音转文字了。
Actually, it's David Sanko's fault because we were at some conference and David Sankle was using speech to text to send text messages. And I told him like, oh, why are you doing that? Like, you know, why don't you just type? You know, it's probably faster to type. And my friend Eddie Nolan was there with me. And Eddie believed that he was probably the fastest texter in the group. So him and David had a race to see who could. put out a text message faster and in speaking it was actually you know like twice as fast and so now
其实这得怪大卫·桑科（David Sanko），因为我们在某个会议上，大卫·桑克尔（David Sankle）当时正在用语音转文字发短信。我跟他说，哦，你为什么要那样做？你知道，为什么不直接打字呢？你知道，打字可能更快。我的朋友埃迪·诺兰（Eddie Nolan）当时和我在一起。埃迪认为他可能是小组里打字最快的人。所以他和大卫比赛看谁能更快地发出短信，结果说话确实比打字快两倍，所以现在
I've I've started doing the speech to text instead of typing on the phone okay it's uh it's Copenhagen which is the Copenhagen metro area is 1.3 million uh the arhus uh city of arhus is uh 280 000 so pretty big drop off there really and yeah told me uh 380 Oh, this is, this is from pretty interesting. And then the next one is Odens, Odens, which is
我开始用语音转文字代替手机打字了。好的，它是哥本哈根，哥本哈根大都会区有130万人，奥胡斯市有28万人，所以下降幅度相当大。是的，他告诉我38万。哦，这很有趣。然后下一个是欧登塞（Odens），欧登塞，也就是
180. And yes, there's a pretty big drop off. It's got one of those, it's one of those countries where there's just that one big giant metro area. And for the listener, you might have just heard some loud background noise. They've got some construction on the road,
18万。是的，下降幅度相当大。这个国家就是那种只有一个巨大大都会区的国家。对于听众来说，你刚才可能听到了一些嘈杂的背景噪音。路上正在施工，
which is making it very loud. And I have gone to the furthest, rightmost lane. and it is now very quiet but we are going very slow so I would just like you know we have sacrificed some time and it's our ETA initially was 1257 it's 1247 now and at 1 p.m. local time
这让声音变得非常大。我已经换到了最右侧的车道，现在安静多了，但我们开得很慢，所以我只是想说，我们牺牲了一些时间，我们最初的预计到达时间是12点57分，现在是12点47分，下午1点当地时间
is the 5,000 meter heats for the world athletics championships that is happening in Tokyo right now and my boy Grant Fisher who finished six in the 1,500 meters real disappointing double bronze in the Paris Olympics he's my favorite runner
是世界田径锦标赛的5000米预赛，现在正在东京举行。我的好兄弟格兰特·费舍尔（Grant Fisher）在1500米比赛中获得了第六名，在巴黎奥运会上获得了双铜牌，他是我最喜欢的跑步运动员，
he studied at Stanford which not most runners do. Anyways, he's got his chance at redemption. It's only the heats, so obviously he's going to be in the top six or whatever, have to qualify. But I'm hoping to watch the 5,000 meter heats, and I'm just letting you know, listener, I'm sacrificing potentially watching that live. Oh, and guess what? The noise is back because even the rightmost lane does not have a nice driving experience. So we're going back to the left, and the time that I said was being saved is not, and the audio quality is going to be poor. Part of the experience. Part of the experience.
他在斯坦福大学学习，大多数跑步运动员都不会这样做。总之，他有机会实现救赎。这只是预赛，所以很明显他会进入前六名之类的，必须获得资格。但我希望能观看5000米预赛，我只是想告诉你，听众，我可能要牺牲观看直播的机会了。哦，猜猜怎么着？噪音又回来了，因为即使是最右侧的车道也没有好的驾驶体验。所以我们要回到左边，我刚才说节省的时间并没有节省，音频质量也会很差。这是体验的一部分。这是体验的一部分。
So, oh, okay, can we, should we talk about the thing that you spoke about? Not yet. Not yet? We'll talk about it. Actually, when is this going to come out? I mean, you get to decide when it comes out. Well, I mean, there's two edited podcasts already. I edited the part one and part two, which are coming out as the third and fourth episodes of Sean.
所以，哦，好的，我们可以，我们应该谈谈你刚才说的那件事吗？还没到时候。还没到时候？我们会谈到的。其实，这期节目什么时候发布？我的意思是，你可以决定它什么时候发布。嗯，我的意思是，已经有两期剪辑好的播客了。我剪辑了第一部分和第二部分，它们将作为肖恩（Sean）的第三和第四集发布。
So that's going to be, you've already listened to that in the past by now, but it is, what is it today? September 19th. Holy shit. Yeah, 19th. Right. The podcast, I need to launch. Oh, you were going to do it from the train, and we're not on the train. Yeah, we're six hours ahead.
所以那将是，你现在已经听过那些了，但今天是几号？9月19日。天哪。是的，19号。对。播客，我需要发布。哦，你本来打算在火车上做，但我们不在火车上。是的，我们快了六个小时。
So that means an 8. And 8. An 8 a.m. release is at 2 p.m. So it should be fine, but I totally forgot. I was about to say, yeah, the two upcoming episodes are on the 19th of the 26. And, ooh, we're on a big bridge. and that means that this episode we're probably seeing as we're not talking about technical stuff
这意味着8点。8点。早上8点的发布时间是下午2点。所以应该没问题，但我完全忘了。我正想说，是的，接下来的两集是在19号和26号。哦，我们在一座大桥上，这意味着这一集我们可能是在看，因为我们没有谈论技术方面的东西，
as you probably made it what 30 minutes into this episode although we did mention the Roku folks that's technicalish I'll probably release this as one big one hour or whatever 40 minute episode however long we end up chatting for so that'll be on what October I don't know if it's the first second third something like that
因为你可能已经听了这一集的30分钟了，尽管我们提到了Roku的人，那算是技术性的。我可能会把这一集发布成一个一小时或者40分钟左右的长集，不管我们最后聊了多久，所以那大概会在10月，我不知道是1号、2号、3号还是哪一天，
but yeah let's hold off talking about that and we uh I mean we'll talk about it later on this trip, and then it'll get released. Ah, okay, okay, okay. At that point, we'll probably... Because I was thinking what we should do is we should, you know, we should do it like a guest interview, where I should interview you about,
但是的，让我们先别谈那个，我们，我的意思是，我们会在这次旅行的晚些时候谈论它，然后它就会发布。啊，好的，好的，好的。到那时，我们可能会……因为我在想我们应该做什么，我们应该，你知道，我们应该把它做成嘉宾访谈，我应该采访你关于，
like, oh, so Connor, tell me about this project you've been working on, you know? We'll do that, but my voice is fading, too, so... Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, let's talk about what we're planning on doing in Copenhagen and then the rest of our trip, and maybe we can wrap this up. Link in the show notes for the Roku Engineering Symposium. if you are in or near Denmark next year, roughly the same time, assuming that they've always done it in the past in Orhus.
比如，哦，康纳（Connor），跟我说说你一直在做的这个项目，你知道吗？我们会那样做，但我的嗓子也快哑了，所以……是的，是的，是的。好吧，让我们谈谈我们计划在哥本哈根做什么，以及我们剩下的行程，也许我们可以结束这次谈话。Roku工程研讨会的链接在节目说明里。如果你明年在丹麦或附近，时间差不多，假设他们过去一直是在奥胡斯举办的。
Check it out. It is invite only, but the public is invited. And tonight, and that's the reason we got the car, is because we could have hung around the train station and crossed our fingers and hoped that the track issues were fixed. But Bryce did not want to take that chance. So we booked the car so that we can be at the Copenhagen C++, meetup, we're going to hang out with some more Danish folks, number two country per capita.
去看看吧。这是仅限受邀者参加的，但公众也被邀请。今晚，这也是我们租车的原因，因为我们本可以在火车站徘徊，祈祷轨道问题能解决。但布莱斯（Bryce）不想冒险。所以我们预订了车，这样我们就能参加哥本哈根的C++聚会，我们要和更多的丹麦人聚在一起，这是人均排名第二的国家。
And we're both going to be giving the same talks again, modern C++ for GPUs for Bryce and postmodern C++ for GPUs for me. And I think there's a social or whatnot. I assume there's going to be some socializing. We're going to hand out some stickers. And that's going to be it for tonight, I think, right? Yeah, yeah, I think that's it. And then the day after we have finally day of rest on Saturday, so we're going to just be in Copenhagen, going to maybe go check out some things in the city, because I don't think either of us have been there before. And then day after that, on Sunday, we fly out to Toaslo, and we take the train to Kongsburg for in D.C. Techtown, and we've got two tutorials, one on Kuta C++, one on Kuda Python. I am, in
我们俩都会再次做同样的演讲，布莱斯讲现代GPU C++，我讲后现代GPU C++。我想会有社交活动之类的。我假设会有一些社交。我们会分发一些贴纸。我想今晚就这样了，对吧？是的，是的，我想就这样。然后第二天，我们终于在周六有一个休息日，所以我们只是待在哥本哈根，可能会去看看城市里的一些东西，因为我觉得我们俩以前都没去过那里。然后第二天，周日，我们飞往奥斯陆，然后乘火车去孔斯贝格（Kongsberg）参加NDC Techtown，我们有两个教程，一个是Kuta C++，一个是Kuda Python。我，实际上，
fact right now testing the Kudu-C-plus-plus one and then I've got to talk at the conference and then I head back. I actually fly back through Finland and then you're going to stick around for I'll be there for one day of the conference. I think you're going to stick around there for for both days at the conference and then that'll be the end of our little our little tour, a little Europe tour. Yeah and we'll have to, we're probably going to run out of stickers. We'll, we'll say that discussion for when it happens. And if we do, we'll be back. We'll be back.
现在正在测试Kudu C++那个，然后我还要在会议上演讲，然后我就回去了。我实际上是经芬兰飞回去的，然后你会留下来……我会参加一天的会议。我想你会留下来参加两天的会议，然后那将是我们的小欧洲之旅的结束。是的，我们可能会用完贴纸。我们会把那个讨论留到发生的时候再说。如果我们用完了，我们会回来的。我们会回来的。
I mean, we clearly have to come back to Scandinavia as this is where the people are. This is where the listeners are. Yeah, I'm excited. What, is there anything else we need to chat about in this episode? I don't think so. I think we can wrap it up. We've got two hours and ten minutes, it says, until we get to Copenhagen. Are we supposed to record anywhere?
我的意思是，我们显然必须回到斯堪的纳维亚，因为这里有人。这里有听众。是的，我很兴奋。还有什么我们需要在这一集里聊的吗？我不这么认为。我想我们可以结束了。距离我们到达哥本哈根还有两个小时十分钟。我们应该在什么地方录音吗？
I don't know. I mean, I think, I don't, I think not at the meetup, but presumably at NDC will, you know, run into some people we would want to record with or something. You, do you know, uh, I mean, this will all be in the past for the listener, but do you know off the top of your head who are the speakers that are speaking at NDC Techtown? I know, Jason's going to be there. I know, I don't know who else. I think maybe Hauna's there, I'm not sure. I think Hauna's there as well. Yes, it will be the first time being to a C++ conference in a long time for me. Like, when was the last C++ conference you were at?
我不知道。我的意思是，我想，我不认为在聚会上录，但大概在NDC，我们会遇到一些我们想一起录音的人之类的。你知道，我的意思是，这对听众来说已经是过去式了，但你知道NDC Techtown有哪些演讲者吗？我知道杰森（Jason）会去。我知道，我不知道还有谁。我想也许哈娜（Hauna）也在，我不确定。我想哈娜也在。是的，这将是我很长一段时间以来第一次参加C++会议。比如，你上次参加C++会议是什么时候？
Good question. It could have been ACCU, because most of the conferences I've been at Python conferences this year. Yep. So, haven't seen the C++ folks. It'll be good to catch up. Yeah, yes, it will. All right, well, let's wrap it here. Let's hope that worked. Be sure to check these shows. notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in
好问题。可能是ACCU，因为我今年参加的大多数会议都是Python会议。是的。所以，还没见到C++的朋友们。能叙叙旧会很好。是的，确实会。好吧，那我们就在这里结束吧。希望录音成功。请务必查看这些节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在ADSP thepodcast.com上，获取我们提到的任何内容的链接，
today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的口号。这不是口号。我们的口号是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。